joining us now House Minority Whip Steve
Scalise Florida congressman Matt Gaetz
good to see you both congressman Scalise
we start here there's no stopping it
this is what they wanted this is what
we've heard we've run montages 2016 2017
2018 and all through 2019 impeach their
favorite word what are the consequences
in your view well the consequences are
that this is going to be a stain on
Nancy Pelosi s legacy the fact that this
was an impeachment in search of a crime
and they never found a crime Sean and
instead of moving on their most radical
base when an impeachment regardless of
whether or not the president did
anything wrong and so they went after it
anyway instead of doing the things that
they could have been doing to work with
this president to lower drug prices to
address so many other problems in our
country and so I think that's gonna be
something they're gonna have to live
with it would be the first time in
history shown by the way that an
appeasement of a president happened on a
party-line vote the only bipartisan vote
will be against impeachment and again
that's going to be a stain on Pelosi's
legacy of Speaker Matt Gaetz you're
watching this unfold I will say this
this has brought the Republicans people
like yourself to the forefront fighting
for what truth is fighting for due
process the idea that they ran this
through so quickly they only on one fact
witness all hearsay an opinion witnesses
I mean it's it's it's remarkable in
terms of the depth of depravity and the
lack of seriousness and this it makes no
sense because politically there's no way
that they get away with this without
paying a price that's right I said after
President Trump released the transcript
of his perfectly fine call that Nancy
Pelosi had been functionally catfished
into an illegitimate impeachment
tomorrow we will not win the vote but we
have won the argument and then a result
of that is going to be we're going to
win the election now I know Adam shifts
dog may not be named impeach but I think
it's the American people that are going
to have Adam Schiff in the doghouse when
they see that our country has been
divided and distracted with no crime no
victim
and terrible process as the results of
the Democrats having no agenda for the
country
congressman gates congressman Scalise
thank you both for all you've been